I will first try to address the consumer
protection and consumer financial
regulatory body we're all consumers I'm
a consumer and everybody in America is a
consumer so fundamentally I'm not
opposed to creating a consumer
protection division of a Prudential back
a bank regulator I think we should but I
am opposed to creating it outside the
Prudential regulator because the number
one issue with banks and it is a
consumer issue is the safety and
soundness of banks today we have a lot
of banks that are still sick or in
trouble and there will be a lot of bank
failures in the year 2010 so the fur the
first order of business is a sound
banking system that one can take your
deposits that you can sleep at night
with and feel good about that will be
able to make you loans and so forth but
at the same time being a consumer I
think that they should look at some of
the consumer aspects of the banking
system and i believe the prudential
regulator that is the regulator that
deals with safety and soundness is the
proper one to do that
well I think if you look back at the
troubled asset relief program tarp I
posed that from the beginning one I
thought that a lot of institutions
started out at financial institutions
were not too big to fail that although
they were big we shouldn't let them fail
and we would have been better off it
would be a lot more efficient it would
have not been without pain but we would
be a lot of head of the game today than
we are so am I trouble with Treasury
that and the federal reserve was the
intervention there I think we could have
done better we could have done it
different ways but only history will
tell that and I would contend that
nothing's too big to fail
I think it's mixed I think as far as our
banking system is concerned the Federal
Deposit Insurance Corporation headed by
sheila bair i think that the FDIC has
been on top of things they've closed
down a lot of banks which they have to
do as a regulator they've probably mixed
like everybody else I think the worst
regulation by any agency was the Federal
Reserve over the bank holding companies
most of those banks not all most of
those banks are the truck where the
trouble banks and the ones that caused
the most heartburn
well first of all I was the leader in
trying to make sure that Fannie and
Freddie did not fail and did not cost
the taxpayers a lot of money mixed up in
all the financial crisis was the role
that Fannie and Freddie played also the
rating agencies Moody's S&P Fitch rating
instruments that is securities
investment grade Triple A grade and all
that's when in reality they weren't I
was the one that authored the
legislation to bring competition and
give the SEC which they have now more
power to deal with the people who rate
credit SEC the week on the rating the
company's agencies
I would hope they would be privatised as
soon as possible right now in early 2010
of Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac are
probably the only people that are really
buying mortgages to to a great extent in
the secondary market so they're they're
the game in town but on the other hand
when we create hybrid vehicles like we
call them government-sponsored
enterprises GSE we're waiting for
trouble in my judgment and I saw that
coming five years before I was hoping
that we could privatize them totally
make sure that they were strong and make
them work in the market without an
implicit guarantee by the taxpayers that
didn't work out so now the taxpayers own
for most part of fatty Freddie and
Fannie and what the debt is going to be
at the end of the day we don't know yet
I opposed any I believe it's in 1999 I
think I was the only Republican that
voted against the repeal of
glass-steagall because it had worked for
years what he did basically a separate
investment banking which is highly
leveraged banking from commercial
banking which is highly regulated when
you repealed glass-steagall you put it
on in commercial banking and you've seen
a lot of problems that come with it we
were assured then but I didn't believe
it at the time that they would not be
putting the taxpayers at risk you know
by doing this now we know better than
that now the question is can we change
that I don't know if we can ever go back
to glass-steagall as it was but but the
regulator's can do a lot toward making
sure that the commercial banks don't
jeopardize themselves by their
investment banking or proprietary
trading
I don't know if we can reinstitute
glass-steagall some people have
advocated dr. Volkers advocated it
Senator McCain and others have because
once something is past is past but I
think that we if we can't do that that
we certainly could make sure through the
regulatory process that the taxpayers
are not put it in harm's way
well you ask a lot of questions there
the fannie and freddie they're going to
be gone it's a question and they're
already gone as far as available you
know private or hybrid enterprise the
question is how long we be before the
private sector can pick up the role that
they're doing and what will that role
will that be as far as the mortgage
deduction you know that's very popular
in America well with and it's probably
aided and abetted a lot of homeownership
so that's probably something that most
people wouldn't touch
well I don't believe you'll ever reduce
the unemployment rate in any meaningful
way with stimulus in other words with
government spending because once the
stimulus is spent generally the jobs are
gone what we need to do is revitalize
our banks where they can make loans to
small and medium-sized businesses and
let the market work the market
ultimately is probably going to be the
only thing that that brings unemployment
down from the high levels that they are
today
well I have never to my knowledge voted
for taxes I don't plan to vote for him
in the future because the the spinning
of the government will always outrun the
taxes we have programs that are in fact
right now we're spending too much in
taxes if we tax everybody ninety percent
it wouldn't take care of our problems it
might aid and abet someone but then we
take that money out of people's pockets
and we do real damage to the economy so
if people are advocating taxes is a way
to close our deficit I think that's a
short term and I think it's a flawed
argument
well I believe a flat tax would be fair
for a lot of reasons I have advocated
the flat tax on a number of occasions
one it would lower people's taxes tax
burden they would have more money to
spend that have more that'd be good for
the economy that have more money to say
which would be good for future
investment and job creation in this
country and the in a family under my
proposal a family of four that made I
believe thirty six thousand eight
hundred dollars pay no taxes at all we
would become a nation of savers and
status spenders and there would not be
deductions because you wouldn't need
them you'd have more discretionary money
well first of all we have advocated a
number of things but our Democratic
colleagues and friends have not met us
halfway and I don't think they intend to
meet us halfway they got the majority in
the House and the Senate I don't know
what's going to happen with the Senate
bill that has gone to the house now I
hope it won't pass but in maybe now with
us having 41 votes in senate 40 that we
could come back and work something with
Democrats that would be meaningful it
would be a scaled-down version of health
reform that we could agree on and I
believe that would be in thinking
thinking like the majority over hundreds
are the American people think now look
at the polls
oh I think the Republican Party is
beginning to rebuild itself just like
the Democratic Party did after the 94
Democratic debacle and this will take a
number of years but you see a lot of
life out there you saw what happened in
New Jersey you saw what happened in
Virginia he sold just what happened in
Massachusetts and I think later this
year you'll see a big reaction to a lot
of the Democratic policies headed by the
Obama administration